each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
a topic is the military database and
Vanessa historic I'm leave from the si
si si senior program manager let's go
through the agenda of legislation we
have foot hopping the first one is
sickly and lvm the last one is the
minister or 60 days all of this is about
relational database the last tool is the
about minister or storage we have some
feature in the start in for data we have
the table starch and the folder battery
data we have the probe story as we know
we have a many filter in the error such
as the messaging and catching networking
militaries of all of these are packaged
into the building block for data we have
four we have a three offering big data
is talk about the Hadoop database and
the database is for the relational
database we have to type of relief to
know database why is the as I mentioned
the nice the SICU vm and neither is a
second error under the the three at the
third one is the storage we have some
some some features in the storage we
will talk part in the later big data as
we know big data is very hot topic in
that in the industry we have many new
tips all such as a device sensor and
also we have to handle many new
non-traditional d-type many texts while
and video photo and stream under stream
okay this
of a death hype and distance we have to
face to the larger mouth to death bottom
okay maybe some people want to know what
had that the big data can answer we need
some new insight from the big litter
from tech guys we want to know how to
get the insights from the big reader
maybe the clouds is a very income node
mode let's talk about the ad rated
measurement as mentioned we have full
option in the dead amendment the first
tool is the relational as too deep into
the sink p.m. Microsoft apply the
convenience offering from the private to
the public how we have some box software
such as a sick server in the server we
had we can handle the sorry
we can use the Venus server and the six
server mr. halfway to handle the
physical and the virtual machine we also
offer the SVM on the head or we can
bring the sick server to the ground this
is a very interesting and very very easy
to make you a solution to migrate to the
cloud making it very easy because the
you didn't need to change anything you
can just a memory to database you ndu
application from the virtual machine to
ask them because the architect and hyper
is rare is the same so you didn't pay
for some Mike reaching the cost another
user about the rich network you can use
the rich networkers to connect you cough
night to the virtual machine on the
cloud another over easter is about the
past where possible we can offer the
secure a deal pays for the new
application you can use the C sharp
donate and PHP to access the Aleutian
the database there is down the cloud for
secure server in the virtual machine you
can get full capability of the six
server this means you can get her h a
feature is the OS on you can get a PA
feature based analysis service and the
integration assist and the Republic
series you also can get the security
which the transparent data extra
encryption and the out in the theater
this is the building feature for the
sixth server another one is a load TCO
because you further existing application
you didn't
of me to migrate or change anything you
can migrate to the application to the
cloud it's very easy you can use the
familiar development framework you can
use the same man from the monumental
application and the morning application
you can use the same tools it's the same
with with you I'm promised tip Center
under the clown the flexibility and
control because this is just a vm you
can get the OS you can get the green
account you can get the login you can
control the vm you can install the
software you can change the config of
the OS and the six server so you can get
all of the vm another is the if
structure the if structure is a member
by the vena sera you didn't take care
the hardware and the disk the street and
the network we can we can support a 39 s
array for the virtual machine so you can
get loose and then the last one is a
control the better in this area there
are some common scenario for the vm 46
server the first one is the mac reach
the tier 1 achieve the tier 2 and tier 3
application from the i'm from this entry
to the hydro p.m. the second one is the
beauty UT welcome the entice the
environment on the cob you know if you
want to build a las care-a-lot eyes you
need too many machines to add load to
the database but in the cloud it's very
easy you did it to pay you didn't need
to pay to the hardware to the software
you just the painful they use it you can
build a last
err a load test agent you can use the
agent to get more load to the six error
another one is the Beca back up in the
to sell 2012 sp1 60 you can get her
feature you can use the feature to back
up the database file from a promise
there is entered to the trout you can
save the the becca file to the store
account and the restore from the sole
count to the 2 to the vm in the cloud
this is a typical to miser to build a
not earlier help but HS delusion the
last one is exchanging you local dead
center because you look at this center
maybe have some compelling issue such as
a power networking and the room group
space but in the cloud you didn't care
about that you just use the which
network connect to the cloud and they
extend you the center to the cloud you
can get a more vm you can get more
compute capacity ok let's let's do a
demo about six server to in the error
okay at the very mention that we can use
the main photo to accrete too many types
of vm just need some click new vm and we
can choose the not love the database but
at least this type database is the
second error we just click compute
virtual machine and from gallery we can
have we can offer some type of a secure
image in there we can / aging some some
type of sick stick server it's a
different version just need some click
because this is the vm so we need to
apply the virtual machine name
and the username password
ok
you can assign the size of the vm okay
next we also can control the cloud
forest because the cursor is to have the
public IP also we can create the
endpoint for the cloud service okay we
choose the custom
also we can assign the star account for
the vm at least the stark County's used
to save the virtual machine disk for the
six error he also can add some other
discs for the second server to improve
the LPS okay maybe needed some few
minutes to create a VM but I have crib
have compared when vm for the demo this
is the this one in the any point as we
know 60 have the 6600 need you to open
the 1433 tcp ports to connect to the vm
so we need enable the important in there
but it is not only one for that for the
food for the port because by default we
will be over the security computer
environment so in the oil level we also
have another farewell we have to open
the report in the OS farewell so let's
connect to the
so this Center I used is the indochina
in the pitching
good
in the fair ball I enable the six server
port this means we can connect from the
on-premise the client Oh data center to
access the vm in the edren after that
you can use the you can make it easily
with you familiar tools such as a madman
studio we can use the mattress to do to
connect to the cow cow steer this
service is on the cow is on the cloud so
after I input the login and the password
just click the connect you can get the 6
server on the error we can you can
get food the full control of the vm
because you can get the urban logging in
the council also you can get the IC use
the essay you can get in it you can do
anything in the sixth hour none of them
demo is we can use the migration this is
another instance in my laptop I just
show you how to make rate the database
from the uuuu you do instance under your
data center to the header p.m. it's very
easy you can use them just use the task
you can use the export oh sorry
you can use the eSport day dead here
application okay wizard all of us lacked
a visit we can save the file because I
have a good this one replaced it this
visa they used to migrate the database
from the on-premise they send her to the
arrow vm this wizard will are suited you
will import the database include the
data and the schema and just need some
click on the vm we can import the
application okay click Next not finish
maybe need some a few minutes based on
the data volume of the database you can
migrate the unpermitted base to the vm
also you can use the backup restore
policy to restore the database on the
psycho p.m. because it is vm it's the
same with you I'm promised a center ok
let's probe the table just one table
with a few euros a select ok you see it
was it that data is here it's very easy
a 22 mag read it didn't stick I didn't
change change anything just some visa
and click some button
another another did another offering is
the business address sticker database
video side or secretary basis a
relational database service offering the
in the error past platform it's full
management by men but the by the videos
error this means you didn't care about
the hardware software you just kept the
secret service a secret service we have
the building the HH solution and the
vote for that for the database each
database have at least the three coffee
at SRI coffee we can talk about it later
about the attack of the secure database
okay we open oh we also over the sky
bility and the global reach the future
we can use the familiar framework
microsoft down the video server is very
open we can use the many language stress
as a donut just use the tunnel frame or
and java PHP even you can use the Ruby
pison as okay also we can support some
popular frameworks such as the OData and
a need for more and it happened I i
think the IMP everything work is very
popular in the tower world ok we also
support some popular tools such as some
mmmm studio and the Yaran yaoi is the
death moderate tools is very popular
let's not let's still let's do some demo
about the military secret database but
but but I needed to say the vena sera
database is totally different mr. sick
of the seeker in the vm most of the the
concept to you I show is the wig is the
water
this is the web edition amendment shoes
for the secure database but most of most
of time I like you I like to use the
main studio because the Memphis to do is
very easy and familiar least the web
tools are built based on the right I can
use to choose to to get some reports
such as the active user connection and
the space you used also we can get some
performance query we can get some some
some Prairie status about the quad the
performance who is the top talker about
the cpu I all also we can use these
tools to design we can add table to
define it the schema and we can we can
we can show that dependence in this
database we we have our two object one
is the table name the customer neither
is the week another is the v view name
the VW customer it's very easy it is a
truth let's see more detail in the
advertiser are in the Idaho we can we
have a feed from named in their DB
database in the database we have a tool
concept why is the vice the server not
as the database but the server is not
the physical server is not the physical
server the database is not the physical
database all of this is version it's
but if you want to know ah what is that
what is a waste why do I need my ID to
create the server because the each
server it means you have only one
massive database in the server the
master database is used to control the
login this means the server is used to
control the log in the database the
database is used to arc is a also is a
water container to organize the table
and the database object such as V and
procedure and there are other something
in the inner in the inner database you
can click the server you can get the
dashboard you can get the database in
the server this to database in the word
this database is water is contained at a
richer server it can config such as some
farewell farewell policy and you can get
some our control or control history in
her history but from the but from the
magma tools let's do some demo I let's
connect a secret sicko error of their
ways
you can see the address you can still
address this different vista are sick of
the sequel in the vm i can connect we
will do the same demo in the server I
can list the database in the virtual
server let's do a demo to import and
export the database from the from the
on-premise data center to the sea quiero
database maybe some different with the
sick vm i can do the task and
and there i have in in the in the in the
manual how button to deploy the database
to see Kara it's very simple okay in the
connection in a connection we we will be
a slight one thing is there the
connection did waste we need to connect
to the master database because the only
in the master debase you can create user
database this means firstly you should
connect to the mastery based then in the
master debase you can is cute the Crete
database command to create a new
database so i need to connect to the
mastery based in there okay and then the
new new database name and edition by
default we have to edition of the desire
of security based why is the web edition
neither is the business at addition we
also can control the database size we
have some limitation about windows Aero
secure database the maximum size of the
single database is a 115 gigabytes okay
with this ice isn't enough for the table
okay just click some button the data is
from from the on-premise state of you
patch into the Sun fire at then transfer
the file to the to the error and adder
restore file to the vena sera
most almost complete okay then let's see
in there the new de-risk in the india
under the table is the same just a table
we also can write some some query ok
that is here just need some some some
cake the database migration from the UM
premier state center to their windows
Aero sick Davis it's very easy
let's go deep inside windows Aero
secretary ways we have imagined it's a
different software with the military
secret database and six server in p.m.
we have redesigned the architecture for
the photo for the 30 stories we have
some different layer the first layer is
the tedious gateway tedeschi a tedious
is the common protocol between the
psychic land and the sea server you use
the tds protocol to transfer data log in
and other other other memory ok we use
the tds gateway to to hold the tds chase
function because you know the sixth
server accessories the needed near the
sticks asian needs a fixation so we used
tds get away to hold the station so if
you want to new database you want to
create another device that tedious get
away to hold the test asian and the it
is cute you request in the three copy
this means you have three copy for each
database all of the database is the same
it's the same but as i mentioned that
the debate that the base is a virtual is
not a physical debate it's not the
physical database so the story copy we
have a primary node and another another
two is the rabbit and number two is the
rubric we used we used an earlier to
compete that hae and the load balance
and replication let's go deep in the
gnar
architect it has a few layer the first
one is the plant layer the kind of the
Clanton here is used to buy the
application the application used to the
T is that yes but the the tools such as
a do donate odbc another samsung driver
is support the tds the tedious will come
Kate Vista Service trailer the zoo is
where is the arcade Hawaii between the
clan layer and the platform layer in the
service layer we used to do the some
connection loading connection loading
and the billing and a foraging as I
mentioned the provisioning is just a
create new database server and the new
database the new database in the
physical server just the table this
means i have many many database but in
the fields are all the database is a
group of the tables it's group of tape
tables yeah
and this this is a physical server and
physical server not vm not vm each
physical server we will set up the OS
windows server and the video set up the
six server software we have a single
instance in the filter we also have a
single database this means single
physical database in the physical server
each speech server have a single
secretary instance and single single
server database why why because the
performance performance because the
single database have a single log single
log file we can use the single log file
to improve the lock performance because
the further consistence all of the data
right into the sick sick server he must
write a lot first then retained the
result so the the aisle modem attack the
aisle mode between the log file and the
file is the total difference the log
file need to sequence access this means
they are there are sequence but that the
data file is random he didn't know which
query used which date so to improve that
the database performance we used a
single database in the single server
okay in the inner server we have some
other component wise the stick of fabric
the stick of fabric is you too can show
the low that workload you know the vena
sera secret database is modern debt
tendent database you didn't know who is
in the server who is in this era when
you write a query maybe you feel not
good because there is very slow maybe
you have an odd neighbor you have not
neighbor but but we know but we know the
fabric can migrate some heavy load to
narrow some some some server list this
is a why we suggest you to use the
ritual logic because maybe you have a
noisy user may be that the neighbors
they move to the another server neither
is a member service the man mr. C is
used to the rabbit public data between
the between the street hockey another is
the SoftLayer least there is the method
by the IT we provide a single that this
is the same hardware and networking and
a story twice this is the window cyrus
secret database architect
we also have some feature about the data
the first one is the sick of a duration
the sixth Federation is the used to
scare out you data because I mentioned
we have some limitation the seeker vena
sera secure database the first one is
the is the size single database we can
the single database that the maximum
size is the 115 King buys another is the
works right work started we have some
limitation if you want to mow capacity
of the data and you can you want to get
more performance you should use the
Federation to scale out to scout we can
get we can use this feature to add or
remove database no downtime no downtime
another feature is the secure reporting
is the same vista vm mr. security
policies but but you can use the sticker
reporting to do some bi tools you can
use these three tries the BI tools you
can use the secure reporting to connect
to the Hadoop cluster sick a database or
something we can support that they did a
sauce another one is the secretary think
it's a very important feature you can
use the sequence data sync to connect to
the Emperor's I'm from the center to the
second row database is based on the hour
sync framework you didn't need to rest
any any code just some configuration to
even ok
let's talk about sick address storage
Sicario storage is very important
feature for the agile platform at the
lair imagine the vht for the vm is the
store in the arrow storage so is the
core with Osiris storage this is the UK
Imogen is the thief storage poor in the
in the cow you can you can get a task
scare ball turbo and the available
storage platform in the town ok you can
get the data you can access the data
anywhere in time and and just pay for
they use it it's very reasonable also we
can offer some restful api you can use
the compute error compute computer such
as the vibro and work row to access the
storage also we can open the rest of API
from the you can use the the library in
the mobile phone and add not a device we
are very open we can support Tyson Ruby
JavaScript you're not know jazz and Java
PHP and other some popular language to
access the storage because he's very
important some new feature we have a
bigger release in the last year and in
the last year in the luster a bigger
release we support she'll accept second
offer for the table and the under Q we
can define the permission on the table
such as a table q and the blob container
also we expanded the blob copy we can
support the blob copy between the
different
start on this means you have started
counting the in Beijing and another
store come to you in in Shanghai when
you need to copy a file from Beijing to
Shanghai you didn't need to download and
upload again just use the API we can
copy the blob between the death Sandra
it's very fast also we have some
improvement in the currency and the
mobility in the arrow storage we have to
over while we have 30 prevents the table
storage another is prob another is the
queue let's talk about the table what is
stable table the table is not a
relational database it's a no safer
database you can imagine that is the key
value and they can offer the rest api
and the table support the pure
redundancy we you can have the two table
wiser you can have the multiple copy in
the in the area why you can have three
cop in beijing and another three in the
shanghai in the storage we have some
concept the first one is a cot the
account is the top container for the
storage you can set up some confusion
and the property in the account level
such as the jewelry donzi and monitoring
and this login this is a account level
sightings another concept is the table
table is the container for the
permission you can set to the permission
on the table you can use the share
signature in it on the table also
in the table we can have some entity
each energy have a UK you can set a
different property for that for the
editing also that the entity need to to
key why is the partition key another is
the low key and there's some some
property you need because the table is
the no sequel database because the table
structure is no secretive ways we didn't
there's no fixed schema you can add some
some some some schema or some column as
you need also that dead hype is now
strong type this one the birthday we can
have different format rise the data and
knowledge stream
also you can have some special special
property so this is no fixed schema you
can you can say anything you want in the
table long prop storage prop storage
ease used to start an instructor data
start some photo banner file stream
smooch to video and HD starts them dead
file we can support two terabytes in
single star account but but if you want
to add more capacity it's very easy just
add some new start count okay we have
some limitation to the blob size because
we have to type of blop blop type why is
the page Bob narrows the block block of
you i will talk about this later also is
the durable replication for the disaster
recovery we can set also we also you can
you can disable the feature because the
because the cost let's see some concept
about prop storage okay the table and
the blob storage also need to also need
the account starter cut as i mentioned
that you can set up some account level
sightings in in this container the
sector level container is the east name
the container right you can set set up
the panic permission on this dial the
third one is the file is the file
but each file you also can get some
low-level container el camino this did
this little show we can have to type of
the blob why is the page neither is
block the page blah the page blob is the
optimized for the random excise so the
VHD file is the page below each page
blob file we can support one turbine
another is the blocks you can imagine a
video a video file we often used to
sequence a sequence excise right this is
a random size the block block is
optimized for the further for the for
the streaming also you can use the
blocks blob to push the blob to the
Syrian know some of the image and
streaming video counted you should use
this type also in the block block block
each block is for mac is format this
means if you have a file you defined the
blocks plop if you defile have a hundred
Magpies you should have 20 file blocks
each blocks in formatted right you can
operate the 25 blocks in parallel this
means you can have 20 file 25 tried to
upload the de blob then you just need
one submit request to combine the data
box into the single file this some
optimized
okay let's throw some time
okay in the inner polo we have some
button just is storage in the storage
this is the starter can't we as I
mentioned that we have some some
configured configuration in this style
okay you can enable or disable the
jewelry tansy you can set up the morning
and the login for the each component you
can enable the mountain for the blob for
the table or the queue okay also you can
you can get the access key i use the
diluted key also you can have two key
eat mine is the primary key now there is
a secondary this means you guys reach
the key
the container let's show the container
you can set up some can heater in there
and use the ICS share the access
signature key in this devil let's do
some low to some demo as I mentioned the
map stuffed in the cloud is very open
it's not your studio is the java eclipse
right we can use the Java to write some
application we have some open source
open source client library you can use
the Java in cans the first way you can
new blob time and create the container
and create the blob in the container the
blob file is the from the from the local
file i will upload at a local file to
the prop storage okay the container name
is a test continue unless the chapters
can dinner okay no there s run
it's very uh it's very easy and quickly
okay just to refresh
okay the new container it is here and
the file has been uploaded to use the
client library to make some operate it's
very easy we offer some library in
the Java tonette and the Pisan if you if
you want to use some special language
which we didn't support you also can use
the rest of API to obsess the blob
storage so all of the library is based
on the RESTful API okay
let's go through the storage architect
in the storage we have some some some
like some of the lair the first layer is
the front end the front end server view
will handle all of the request and
response the front end server vo talk
vista sorry
the front the front hand Sarah we talked
with the potential slower in the
precipitation layer we have to tap
surveys the potato server neither is the
petition master potential master is used
to a monitoring the private server right
used to merging the petition server and
he can list this component can get the
load of the workload of the each potato
server and decide which from Hannah
servers should be contact to the special
policy server another area is the TFS
layer is used to store the data and used
to replicate data between the deep
center and inside this design her sick
ability petition is used to render of
entity with the same partition key
petition can find out based on that the
load this means p 1 p 2 pn is a three
partition we can hold the three petition
requesting the single server if the load
is the except successful if the load is
increased we can move some petition from
the server 1 to the third to this server
is the PI server if we get a more
pressure you can with a petition to to
the ministry it's the automatic after
that if I tell that the pressure is
decreased the position you move back
another another keys used to the
scarpetta t is the key we have to type
of the key why is the padishah key
another is the low key if you can apply
the product key and the rookie we can
get the best of the whole performance
because the primary key because the
partition key and the low key just like
the single clustering dives if you can
get this Tiki you can get the best bet
best performance the last page I want to
talk about the Hadoop in vena sera V
over the HD inside is a Hadoop on the
vena sera first system learn some
different with the traditional Hadoop
classroom we use the edge of blob
storage to 282 to replace the HDFS why
because you can create the Hadoop
cluster when you need and you can run
job but after drop is complete you can
in in the error in the HD side you can
delete the classroom all of the data and
the result is stored in the blob storage
this means you use to the pay for you
need when you need scarcer create and
drop and destroy the data is the durable
in the edge of blob storage ok in our
genes life we also support MapReduce hdf
is higher peak and the other a Hadoop
fever
okay all most of our services are Mary
serviced by Venus error you can use the
service as you need I think we can get
enterprise level however ability and ask
ability I wish you can get a good
journal in the cow that's half thank you